un vol à destination de delhi à
l'aéroport pearson de toronto
c'est passager ont chacun leurs raisons
de se rendre en inde malgré la flambée
des cas cet étudiant étranger a perdu un
proche
je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de cas mais
j'ai le mal du pays raconte cet homme
qui de revoir ses parents
mais revenir au canada pourraient être
plus compliquées
le gouvernement trudeau applique le
frein d'urgence nous suspendant tous les
vols de passagers commerciaux et privés
arrivants au canada en provenance de
l'inde et du pakistan
pendant 30 jours le taux de voyageurs en
provenance de l'inde et du pakistan
ayant testé positif à la coved inquiète
les autorités canadiennes des contrôles
s'ajoute aussi pour les vols directs en
provenance de ces pays un test négatif
devra être obtenu au dernier arrêt avant
le canada la pression sur le
gouvernement fédéral s'accentuait
d'heure en heure avec les différents
varien faut être extrêmement prudent
dans une lettre adressée à justin
trudeau le québec et l'ontario lui ont
demandé de serrer la vis à la frontière
canado américaine et de réduire
l'arrivée de vols internationaux
on demande à monsieur trudeau d'en faire
encore plus motion unanime a aussi été
adoptée aux communes pour demander la
suspension des vols de passagers non
essentiel en provenance des pays ayant
auto d'éclosion de variants on dit aux
canadiens de ne pas aller travailler et
de ne pas envoyer leurs enfants à
l'école
au même moment des centaines des vols
internationaux continuent d'atterrir au
canada on s'est trompé la première fois
du côté du gouvernement canadien on a
trop attendu
n'attendons pas les nouvelles
restrictions ont de quoi alimenter les
inquiétudes dans la communauté indo
canadienne
le père de simone val a dû se rendre en
aide en raison de décès d'un proche
nous craignons maintenant qu'ils soient
coincés là bas dit la jeune femme à
cause des annulations de vols mais elle
comprend l'utilité des restrictions pour
combattre les variants face à tant de
pression le gouvernement trudeau ne
pouvait pas se permettre d'attendre plus
longtemps
surtout que depuis le début de la crise
on lui a souvent reproché sa lenteur
vis-à-vis des frontières il voulait sans
doute éviter d'alimenter cette
perception
encore une fois ici louis blouin radio
canada